this video was made possible by
curiositystream when you sign up at
curiositystream.comwendover you'll also
get access to nebula
the streaming site that wendover is a
part of covid19
is a devious disease it's not deadly
enough to kill
a large proportion of its hosts so they
go on to spread it to an incredible
number of individuals
meaning its fairly low mortality rate
has already killed hundreds
of thousands it disguises itself
presenting like a common cold yet can
escalate to something
far more worrisome it also hides with
the possibility of being spread by
someone who does not exhibit
any symptoms whatsoever altogether this
leads to
one simple truth until there is an
effective treatment a vaccine
or herd immunity perhaps the most
important thing a health care system
itself can do to minimize the number of
cases and deaths
is test worldwide diagnostic testing for
coven 19 has ramped up
incredibly fast the first genetic
sequence of the virus was published on
january 5th
and within days the first testing
protocols were published by researchers
in the second half of january the world
was testing hundreds of individuals per
day
by february they were testing thousands
per day then in march
hundreds of thousands and now in july
2020
millions of coronavirus tests are
performed and processed
each and every day believe it or not
though
this is not enough the process has been
mired in issues and
to get to the point where testing can
actually minimize the damage
rather than just quantify it we need to
rethink the system
itself the core of any covit test is a
laboratory method
known as a polymerase chain reaction
this is a commonly used procedure that
copies dna
or through reverse transcription rna
enough so that it can be studied
the various steps in the process
denaturation annealing and elongation
require various specific temperatures
and so performing this process requires
a machine
called a thermal cycler these thermal
cyclers can reach precise temperatures
incredibly quickly and accurately but it
comes at a cost
the cheapest thermal cyclers are priced
in the thousands of dollars but the high
throughput ones used to process covet
tests
often cost in the many tens of thousands
of dollars
therefore at this time it is not
practical for
every doctor's office to have one
especially as many less
automated variants require trained
technicians to operate
there are some faster point-of-care
tests hitting the market but they tend
to be less accurate
more expensive and can process fewer
tests at a time
therefore while samples can be collected
almost anywhere
processing them is a greater challenge
one of the largest
testing providers in the us is a company
called quest diagnostics
at the time of writing they have
processed about 17 percent of
all tests performed in the us and have
the capacity for 130
000 each day they carry out this work in
one of their 28 laps spread out across
the united states
of course it's easy to see that there
are wide swaths of the country without a
lab nearby
so to get samples from where they're
collected to where they're processed
they rely on their own
small logistics network this system
involves plenty of ground transportation
but also in order to quickly transport
samples from far
away areas to the lab they use airplanes
each night after the day samples have
been collected around the country
quest diagnostics fleet of airplanes get
to the sky starting at around 7pm
these 20 or so aircraft are primarily
based in redding pennsylvania and
lawrenceville georgia
as an example on july 16th 2020 one
aircraft
a pilatus pc12 registered as n338qd
took off at 8 45 pm from reading
pennsylvania and flew to elmira syracuse
rochester niagara falls allegheny county
manassas and baltimore where samples
were trucked to a lab a few miles from
bwi airport
the aircraft then returned to reading
pennsylvania by 3 30 a.m
on that night the majority of their
aircraft focused their flights on the
american south though
this is a region without many quest
diagnostics labs and a surge of cases at
that time
another pc-12 for example flew from
lawrenceville georgia to jacksonville
gainesville tampa orlando valdosta
lawrenceville roanoke manassas and
greensboro before returning to
lawrenceville
all in one night filling in the rest of
the routes you can see
just how much ground this small airline
covered in one
night stopping at a large number of
cities and towns going to just a few
labs now in theory a system like this
bringing a whole country's worth of
samples to a few central sites
should provide economies and
efficiencies of scale
and to an extent it does however
other economic concepts have
simultaneously decreased
its effectiveness to start with there's
a heavy supply
and demand imbalance for crucial
equipment to perform a test
about 20 different consumable supplies
are needed including nasal swabs
transport tubes reagents and other
equipment
without any of these 20 items a test
cannot be performed so a bottleneck in
any one of those 20 supply chains stops
testing in addition
economic forces are actually decreasing
overall efficiency
particularly in a country like the us
where testing is overwhelmingly
conducted by private organizations
rather than the government
thousands of providers are each bidding
against each other for equipment
in conventional economics one typically
wants to avoid monopolies and
oligopolies because a few number of
players have too
much power this is why in countries like
the uk for example
where 75 of the grocery market is
cornered by four firms
products like milk are sold for just
about what it costs to produce
farmers barely turn a profit that's
because if a farmer can't sell their
milk to tesco
sainsbury's asda or morrisons they don't
really have
another option so they'll take any price
they can get and meanwhile there are
plenty of farmers so the grocery stores
have plenty of options if one says no to
their low
price meanwhile in the covid test supply
market
the producers have thousands upon
thousands of potential customers the
testing providers
so if one customer won't accept a high
price there are plenty of others and one
that most desperately needs the supplies
inevitably will
if for example the federal government
was the only customer in the u.s
or just the largest one by far the
supply producers would just have to
accept what the government paid
because there would be no alternatives
now resources
might not be allocated as efficiently
using a centrally planned system
but it would at least come at a lower
cost in the real world
the larger providers like labcorp and
quest diagnostics
do have higher buying power processing
more tests per day than most countries
but they still have to compete against
the rest of the world in procuring
supplies
which increases cost in recent weeks
quest diagnostics and other major
testing providers
have been able to collect far more
samples than they have been able to
process
and tests now take up to two weeks or
sometimes more
to come back tests that take so long to
return
are of little use since many
asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic
patients
might not quarantine for that full
period while waiting for results
therefore major focus has been placed on
how to
increase the efficiency of testing for
this
quest diagnostics received the first
emergency use authorization
in the u.s from the fda to implement a
technique known as
pooled testing with this up to four
samples will be combined and tested
together if they generate a negative
result then
all four tests are considered negative
if the group tests positive
then they are separated and tested
individually now if 100 people are
tested traditionally
100 tests will have to be processed but
let's say that 100 people
are tested using pooled testing in the
u.s on average
about 8 percent of tests currently come
back positive so with 100 tests grouped
into 25 pools of 4 you would expect
about 32
percent of those to come back positive
for those positive pools
you then process each test individually
so you will have processed
five times for four results for the 17
pools that came back
negative you only processed once meaning
that altogether
this pooled testing technique used 57
processing slots to generate 100 results
effectively almost doubling capacity
this pooled testing technique though
only works if testing is widespread
enough that only a small portion of
results come
back positive if an average of 20 of
results came back positive
as was the case in the us and early
april the efficiency would diminish
quickly in that case you'd expect to
have to retest
20 of the 25 pools meaning that overall
you'd use 105 processing slots to
generate 100 results
more than if you just tested them all
individually therefore
this technique does not work as well for
testing in hotspots
where positivity rates are far higher
conversely though
if positivity rates are quite low the
efficiency of pooled testing can
increase
as one could efficiently group 8 or 12
or 16 or more tests together
lower positivity rates can be achieved
through collecting more samples
so pooled sampling can increase testing
capacity therefore increasing its own
efficiency
but no matter how fast pcr testing
itself is
it is always a lagging indicator that is
because it takes a number of days for
people to develop symptoms after
exposure
then more days for them to decide to get
tested then more days for the test to
come
back that means that realistically it
will take weeks for significant upticks
in transmission to
show in the data therefore some focus
has been placed on developing
a more real-time indicator for covet
transmission
the solution for that is sewage sewage
is naturally aggregated into a few
processing plants so by testing it for
the presence of kovid's genetic
signature
one can gain a more accurate picture of
how a whole area is doing without the
potential sampling biases of clinical
testing
this technique can show if an area has
coronavirus transmission but it can also
give a big picture view of how
much not only that but in research tests
sewage testing
indicates spikes about a week before
clinical testing meaning it can help
tell governments if they should increase
restrictions before it's potentially too
late to make an impact
but let's go back to the pooled testing
using sewage testing
you can know the relative chance of a
single person from a given area of
having coronavirus
so imagine if you could combine the
sewage testing and clinical pooled
testing into one cohesive system
this technique was proposed by a group
of researchers from berkeley
if you know that say there was a 25
chance of a test from florida coming
back positive you would know that it
would be more efficient to test that on
its own however
if you knew that there was a one percent
chance that a test from north dakota
came back positive you could pool that
test with a large group of other
low risk tests and save processing slots
you could also for example
know that a sample from a healthcare or
retail worker would have
a much higher chance of coming back
positive than a test of a business
person working from home
the berkeley research proposes a system
of machine learning to scale pooled
testing sizes based on risk
factors lower risk samples would be
grouped into large pools and high risk
samples would be grouped into smaller
pools or tested alone
so that pooled testing never leads to an
efficiency disadvantage
no longer the positivity rate the true
genius of pooled testing is that
efficiency
increases as test numbers increase so it
only takes twice the resources to test a
population once daily as it does to test
once monthly
hypothetically a pooled testing system
designed by machine learning could lower
the cost of a test to just three to five
dollars
meaning the frequency of testing could
increase dramatically
now we already know when the crunch time
will be for testing
fall 2020. sometime between october and
december
each year there begins a massive
increase in the number of people
catching the flu
which is highly seasonal covet 19
symptoms closely mirror those of the flu
therefore there will be a massive
increase in people exhibiting covet
symptoms
those people will want to get tested to
rule out the possibility of coronavirus
which means demand will be higher than
ever for testing
even if real infection numbers are lower
all the supplies for testing produced
now
are being used now there is no stash
being built up
which means testing providers and
healthcare systems worldwide have a
hefty task at hand if there is to be any
hope of testing capacity matching demand
in the coming winter like so many things
going on right now
covet testing logistics and its issues
are strongly rooted in
economic theory and there's plenty more
i could talk about but this video was
getting a little too long to still
appease the youtube algorithm so i've
posted an extended cut of this video on
nebula
including discussion of exactly that
nebula is of course
the streaming site that myself and a
bunch of other of the internet's top
educational creators teamed up
to create instead of this ad right now
you could be watching the extended cut
of this video
or any of our other videos early and ad
free or some of our special nebula
exclusive projects
in fact there's a brand new nebula
original going out tomorrow from our
other channel half as interesting or you
could watch tom scott's game show
money which i'm in we're also super
excited that nebula is teamed up with
curiosity stream which is another of the
internet's best streaming sites
home to thousands of fantastic
documentaries and non-fiction shows
like their one on gander international
airport specifically
on how it and the town reinvented itself
as it shifted from being one of the most
important airports in the world
to just another small canadian airfield
together
nebula and curiosity stream are offering
an amazing deal
for a limited time curiosity stream and
nebula are bundled together for less
than fifteen dollars
a year i'm confident in saying that that
is the
best deal in streaming and it's
available only by going to
curiositystream.com
wendover